on the positive side i do think that
when we look at
those young people taking to the streets
the millennials and younger
white and black there is an articulacy
and a clarity of call
about what they want to see change not
just here in our own country
but in places like sydney paris across
the globe
i think also that companies and
organizations
right across our country are doubling
down
and wanting to do more i was speaking to
deloitte's
just last week about their black action
plan for their staff and their
determination to do better
on recruitment particularly in
progression within their organization
and they are typical of many many
businesses ftse 100 companies
across britain but yes it is still the
case
that the profound issues of systemic
racism women for example
dying at four times the rate black women
in childbirth and their white
counterparts
uh young people being stopped nine times
uh more likely than their white
counterparts
by the police those deeper issues
uh will take much much longer and you do
need a government that takes the issues
of systemic racism
seriously and also wants to implement
the countless reviews
and inquiries that have been done in
these areas
okay i mean can i ask about the sort of
the the ally approach to all of this
because one thing that has struck me
um is how little of this
i was aware of i've always thought
myself to be reasonably clued in
and i i a lot of the stuff which is now
coming to the surface
i wasn't even aware was happening at all
now how important is it that
that for a lot of white people in the uk
the blinkers have come off somewhat
very let's be clear black people make up
four percent
of the uk population it's a tiny amount
of people uh relative to the overall
population
so these issues aren't solely
about blackness you could say there's
very little more for someone like me
to say countless music has been made
countless comedy
has been made from eddie murphy to chris
rock countless books have been written
these issues are also about whiteness
they're about the fact that we still
have that lexicon of difference in our
lives
and the outcomes are different for
different people so it's hugely
important this business of
allyship this business of reading
and learning this business of calling it
out
and empathy for our fellow human beings
that are still discovered
experiencing issues of discrimination